like mh370 ended in the southern Indian
Ocean
my heart breaks think of the
unimaginable pain suffered by all the
families I know words which can ease
that mean
I just wanted to loose the mouse with
evidence
you're not searching for a needle in a
haystack we're still trying to find the
high status and whenever there is hope
even if it's against hope we will do
whatever it takes
for the families with the day despair to
interfere
on Monday they got the news they had
feared most as the Malaysian Prime
Minister confirmed that all 239
passengers and crew of flight mh370 were
no longer just missing presumed dead
with deep sadness and regret that I must
inform you that according to this new
data flight mh370 and in the southern
Indian Ocean
today in Beijing overwhelming grief was
accompanied by Hangul
family members of some of the 153
Chinese victims many whom heard the news
via text message targeted the malaysian
embassy public protests are rare in
beijing and this one appears to have
caught the authorities by surprise even
with scores of police there was no
containing the family's grievance they
marched on the embassy demanding a
meeting with the Malaysian ambassador
eventually they were let in to ask one
simple question what do you think
I cannot gas anything with no evidence
I'm not likely but I didn't tell
governments I won't make no suggest
something like that
I just want to choose come out with
evidence what do you think the Chinese
government can do to help you think oh
they will help us to negotiate with the
government to Crescent give us the truth
as soon as possible but they're already
to last night the loss of flight mh370
is an international disaster in
Australia relatives are grieving to
Queenslanders rod and Mary burrows were
on their way to Beijing for a three-week
holiday they leave behind three children
including son Jayden our family is
trying to come to terms with this
terrible tragedy we dearly love and
we'll miss our mum and dad the love and
compassion that they shared and their
priority of putting their family first
will help us get through this together
so many questions in the mystery of
mh370 have yet to be answered the
authorities at least believe they know
what Altima Li happened the Boeing 777s
journey ended in the southern Indian
Ocean Malaysian Airlines reached its
conclusion based on evidence data
provided by British company Inmarsat and
the UK Accident Investigation Branch
according to data gleaned from satellite
handshakes with the plane sometime
between 12 19 and 115 GMT on the morning
of March the 8th it dropped into the sea
families will not rest until they know
how why and most urgently where it
crashed finding that answer will have to
wait at least another 24 hours bad
weather in the search zone made it too
dangerous for the international fleet of
aircraft to take the 1500 mile journey
southwest from Perth into the search
zone
grounded until the weather clears the
search parties were left to contemplate
the scale of their task we're not
searching for a needle in a haystack
we're still trying to define where the
haystack is so that that's just to put
it in in context you're seeing a
multinational effort going on it is
difficult for HMO success to in these
weather conditions be able to find small
bits of debris that is washing around in
the southern Indian Ocean at the moment
search zone is narrowing don't Li
relatively all possible crash sites to
the north of Malaysia have been ruled
out but a vast area remains my only
problem is giving them answer to the
question that they really want to know
which is where we hid our loved ones and
the mh370 is and until we can find that
every debris and then we can confirm
that that the debris is from mh370 oh it
is very difficult for me to have it
among a closure for the families but
what I have indicated to them yesterday
and this will consistent with the
position of the Malaysian government is
that we will do everything within our
powers and this time with 26 other
nations to reduce the search area and
narrow it and as I stated in my
statement earlier by not focusing on the
Southern Corridor we have in fact
narrowed the the area from millions of
nautical miles to and this door is to a
huge task but the narrowing of it
hopefully and I'm very I'm an optimistic
person and whenever there is so even if
it's against hope we will do whatever it
on Monday teams criss-crossing the
search area reported separate sightings
first the Chinese flying sorties out of
Perth reported seeing a white
rectangular object then in a dramatic
development the Australians recorded
another sighting of two items one
circular and grey green in colour the
other rectangular and orange
visually has been clogged
number of likes of you
we've done this is our third flight in
the area
and now we have happy established local
activity
that were any of applause
it starts with the first time we've
actually
certified that we say something is
usually I cap it off right up in front
of anything in the area
obvious question is and these parts of
the missing blank
yeah it's unsure we are theirs
a real way we can I classify that on the
aircraft
we provided
it's possible
well as a location a time
we went to photographers that are the
image analysis
hmm
what she stated the area
HMAS success is currently the only
vessel in the search area ships company
are acutely aware that there are
families of 239 people who are on board
that their craft and we see it as our
role to do whatever we can to provide
them the answers that they deserve but
this is an international effort and help
including from Royal Navy survey ship
HMS echo is on the way while they look
the family's weight as the search for
flight mh370 continues the Malaysian
authorities crisis communications
strategy has come into sharp focus the
families of the 239 passengers and crew
want answers so does the rest of the
world but from the start the Malaysians
insisted they would reveal only what
they know and not speculate and what
they don't and my parent I have always
been persistent and consistent about
trying to locate the plane base and
corroborated and verified information
and you know we've gone through a whole
journey from the South China Sea to the
Malacca Straits right down to the
northern
now to the Southern Corridor and
involves a very complicated process of
looking at satellite radar military
civil primary secondary vessels
investigation and all sorts of needs
that needs to be corroborated at that
particular point in time even so sending
a text to the families telling them
their loved ones had perished in the
Indian Ocean caused hurt and anger fact
now recognized by the airline and then
there was this relatives of missing
passages forcibly removed from a news
conference in Kuala Lumpur
undignified scenes like these turned
fear and frustration to anger and
suggested a lack of control they have
disseminated information timely
information to the media and the problem
was whether it's been accurate
information or not that's something else
they have contradicted themselves a lot
of the information has proved inaccurate
but they didn't set up that information
flow directly to the families real time
given by high-ranking high level teams
which they should have done and that's
how we know they were not prepared for
any sort of disaster what the victims
families have been told is that beyond
reasonable doubt there are no survivors
but closure can only come when the plane
is found skies David Bowden looks at the
challenges the search area is all the
way down there about 1500 miles off the
coast of Perth in Australia they've been
working there for a few days now but it
all stopped because the weather closed
in we had a level seven category of
storm down there to off the maximum of
nine which meant they had waves of six
to nine metres high clearly that was
difficult for the boats it also meant
problems for these planes that are
flying low over the surface they
couldn't get down there now
why are we talking about this search
area at all well that's where Daniel you
come in remember we have the Inmarsat
satellite several days ago coming up
with these pings these electronic
handshakes and then we had a couple of
days ago the direction of this satellite
telling them that they were moving all
the way down here to this search area
first of all Daniel tell us how they did
each plane under the an image that
constellation has a unique frequency
it's a defined frequency within a
certain width so each plane traveling
along the Southern Corridor will have a
slight frequency change in the signal so
when they disseminate the information
they can look at all the registered
flight paths and say okay that is mh370
frequency and they can hone the system
into that one and say okay and 1451 it
was in this position because we had this
frequency and it was doing the handshake
to say hello mister satellite I'm here
as it were the PAP hasn't Swift the half
a signal was that could mean anything
did the plane let me just explain that
half a signal because that is new news
isn't it we knew we'd have these pings
then we're told at this morning's news
conference there's a half a ping
whatever that is sometime after we
thought the plane was down what's a half
a ping and how could it happen
half a pin can be in magnitude of things
but to me it's basically the radar
signal got cut off halfway through the
system it told it
itself dates there but kind of didn't
transmit the full picture so it might
have included height bearing of
direction and the timestamp but if it's
cut off halfway through they might only
just have a bearing so they have no
exact position on that plane clearly
we're not in the Indian Ocean and we're
not close to this investigation but do
we think that's significant or is it
just a blip if you like it might just be
an admiration at the total cost but may
I be I believe are investigating it so
they've got multi-million pound computer
simulations that should be able to
determine whether it is a relevant piece
of info or whether it's nothing there
isn't enough info from that handshake to
say or determine where that plane
actually was at that time so the
challenge now is to find what's left of
the plane in the most extreme conditions
it calls for a highly specialized
skilled operation you really need to be
very very close to that acoustic pinger
to be able to hear it to give you an
example if we're talking 4000 meters of
water you know you can't be on the
surface and hear it you need to be you
know a few hundred meters away and
possibly you know a few hundred meters
to either side no more than 1,500 2,000
meters beyond that you probably won't
hear it the TPL is normally deployed
from oceanographic research vessels
towed from a very long steel cable on a
winch a hydraulic winch that can put it
down at the bottom and pick it up to
make sure that it doesn't hit anything
and the operators control that and try
to fly it we call it flying it very
close to the seabed as close as possible
the speed is very slow because that
cable in the water has a great amount of
hydrodynamic drag on it you can't go
fast doing this you generally towing at
a couple of knots and you're trying to
be as quiet as possible trying to have
the best weather conditions as possible
so that instrument is not moving up and
down in the water
column is possible as minimal as it
possibly can and you're just very very
quietly listening for that pinger and
all you need is a handful of pings to
say we're there and then once you've got
that location then you triangulate it by
several different turns around it and
get as many things as you can on the
object the question of why the aircraft
went down is still unanswered and may
prove as challenging as the search early
suspicion fell on flights captain fifty
three-year-old zaharie Ahmed Shah he's a
vastly experienced pilot in more than
eighteen and a half thousand flying
hours under his belt the first officer
was Fariq Abdul Hamid 27 and joined
Malaysian Airlines in 2007 it was fairly
new to this model of aircraft a Boeing
triple7
200
this CCTV shows the two men going
through security on their way to board
the flight that evening
we're told they did not specifically
request to fly together
police have started searching their
homes talking to friends and neighbors
they found this flight simulator in
captain zaharie's house investigators
say that some data on it has been
deleted but the flight manifest hold the
answers investigators are scrutinizing
all 239 names more than two weeks after
the planes disappearance was still
learning more about the men women and
children who were on board this flight
Chandrika Sharma was heading to Mongolia
via Beijing to attend a United Nations
meeting on food and agriculture her
husband and daughter are inconsolable
the youngest passenger on the flight was
two years old the oldest 76 seven of
them were children will never reach
their fifth birthdays 26 year old un
Chow is originally from Mongolia we
moved to study business at whole
University in England gone home to see
his girlfriend
Mukesh Mukherjee and his wife is I'm
Albay had been on a beach holiday
together in Vietnam the two young sons
were waiting for the home 15 different
nationalities were flying to Beijing
that night among them 153 from China 38
from Malaysia five Indians for French
three from the United States two Iranian
's on board became initial suspects but
seemed to have been ruled out 35 year
old Joo Koon is a stuntman and was due
to start work on a new series for
Netflix in Malaysia next week he was on
his way to Beijing sees two children Bob
and Cathy Lawson are from Springfield
Lakes in Australia they have three
daughters and described as doting
grandparents Paul weeks is a mechanical
engineer he accidentally left his
wedding ring and watched behind him at
home when he travelled to Mongolia for
work Hadrian were trail offs on the
right is 17
jyan on the left 18 they were on their
way to school in Beijing
at every turn the mystery of flight
mh370 is defied simple explanation each
new lead
every new sighting each new dataset has
posed more questions than it is answered
so the search goes on on land and sea
for the relatives now mourning their
loss
there will be no easy conclusion
you